[Musique]
je voudrais qu'on survole un peu votre
carrière
je crois que le premier grand succès 7
et ballades soukra pradines
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
alors en suivant en suivant la
chronologie j'ai noté a comme amour
c'est ça
et
pas
oui
je cours
oh
à
non
alors ensuite ensuite y ait une lettre à
ma mère m'a parlons-en
votre maman à la [ __ ] ou écouter alain
bittar hommes ville aux mavs ils nous
regardent ce soir elle a pas encore eu
l'occasion de faire le tour du monde
avec son fils est à romainville d'un
autre caméraman de la 3 gérard esnault
sa maman habite roma vit légalement mais
lui bien heureusement n'a pas encore
vendu 30 millions de disques alors
lettre à ma mère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
on
bien ont permises survol avec une
chanson qu à buckingham tout le monde
connaît est-ce que moi vous l'avoir
envoyé puisque le titre s'appelle lady
di ou l'avant voyez ça les parties la
main mais c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
j'ai eu beaucoup de succès en angleterre
mu paris ces titres-là abondamment des
allées aussi loin d'arranger ça les
vidal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]